trump is nominated for the nobel peace
prize the oscars announced that the best
picture nominees must now comply with
woke
guidelines and major city police leaders
begin to quit i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now at expressvpn.com we'll
get to all of the breaking news and
there's a lot of it
in just one moment first let's talk
about that cell phone bill so you've
been racking up big charges
on your cell phone bill have you not and
you haven't been using all that data
you've been paying for unlimited data
in the weird opinion you'll be using
unlimited data you're not in fact using
unlimited data you're using very limited
data and you're paying way too much and
this is why
you need to use puretalk instead of like
at t verizon
t-mobile they all want to charge you for
data and perks that you're never going
to use puretalk
will give you the exact same coverage
the same towers the same bars but
they cost you half with no contract and
no excessive fees you can save a ton of
money
on pure talk usa i mean we're talking
like hundreds of dollars a year right
now
enjoy unlimited talk text two gigs of
data all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400 bucks a
year
on their wireless bill so here's how you
do it grab your mobile phone
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro when you
do you save 250 bucks off any iphone
including the new iphone se again
that is pound two five zero say keyword
ben shapiro pure talk usa simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now no
reason for you to spend too much
on that cell phone bill just get it
simplified at puretalk puretalk usa same
coverage as any other company
and you're doing it for way less money
pure talk usa save 250 bucks off any
iphone when you dial pound 250 and say
keyword ben shapiro to get started with
puretalk usa
okay so the world is a flame and it's a
flame
because wait for it wait for it donald
trump has now been nominated for a nobel
peace prize which is hilarious
so the reason it's hilarious is because
everybody's gonna react
with with just utter amazement
astonishment
shock people are going to be appalled
you're going to see cnn today melt down
how could trump this giant orange
buffoon
be nominated for a nobel peace prize
well a norwegian parliamentarian has now
nominated trump for the nobel peace
prize it was submitted
by christian tybring jedi a member of
the norwegian parliament who allowed
trump for his efforts to resolving
protracted conflicts worldwide
he's a foreign member of parliament he
serves as chairman of the norwegian
delegation
to the nato parliamentary assembly now
remember trump
was widely perceived as the anti-nato he
did not pull out of nato
shetty said for his merit i think he's
done more to try to create peace between
nations than most other peace prize
nominees
he said the trump administration has
played a key role in the establishment
of relations between israel and the uae
the united arab emirates
as it is expected other middle eastern
countries follow will follow in the
footsteps of the uae this agreement
could be a game changer that will turn
the middle east into a region of
cooperation and prosperity
he wrote also cited in the letter was
the president's quote key role in
facilitating contact between conflicting
parties and creating new dynamics and
other protracted conflicts
such as the kashmir border dispute
between india and pakistan and the
conflict between north and south korea
as well as dealing with the nuclear
capabilities of north korea also he
praised trump for withdrawing a large
number of troops
from the middle east he said indeed
trump has broken a 39 year old streak of
american presidents either starting a
war or bringing the united states into
an international armed conflict
the last president to avoid doing so was
peace prize laureate
jimmy carter now this is not the first
time that trump has been nominated
this same norwegian parliamentarian
submitted a nomination for trump in 2018
after
trump met with kim jong-un in 2018
japan's prime minister reportedly
did the same and tried bringing shady is
a member of a conservative leaning
populist party
in norway he said i'm not a big trump
supporter but the fact is that
a lot of people have gotten the prize
for doing a lot less he said quote for
example barack obama did nothing
that is fair that is true you'll recall
that even when barack obama won the
nobel prize he's like what
why am i here i don't even know i guess
just because i'm breathing and because
i'm the first black president so nobel
prize for me
okay it was very weird his noble peace
prize acceptance speech was was very
awkward okay
the fact is that trump's foreign policy
has actually been the best part of his
administration so i know a lot of people
are into the judges and some are into
the cuts to to the regulatory state some
people are even into the tweets although
i would say that bipolar number is not a
huge number
but the fact is just on an objective
level trump's foreign policy has been
the most successful part
of his administration and that doesn't
mean that i agree with everything
trumpian
about foreign policy i think that his
treatment of kim jong-un was ridiculous
i thought that it was completely
mishandled i i never thought that that
hanging out with kim jong-un was going
to change anybody's
mind i never liked his kind words about
vladimir putin early on in his
administration but
trump's anti-china stance has been quite
transformative for a number of countries
including taiwan
trump's willingness to face up to the
problem of china is going to have long
and far-reaching applications for the
next couple of decades of american
history
especially should he be re-elected if
joe biden is elected there's a reason
that china is stumping
for biden to be elected in trump's place
and most of all
in the middle east trump's activity has
been utterly transformative i mean the
fact is
that the israel uae deal that got cut
just a few weeks ago
the normalization of relations between
israel and the uae that is the first
peace deal in the region since 1994
when jordan signed a deal with israel it
is the first long-lasting peace deal
since 94 and
before that since israel and egypt cut a
deal and it is the most transformative
deal in a certain way because
it is full normalization of relations
it's not a cold piece
it's much more like a warm piece in
which there is exchange of
economic information and in which there
is security cooperation
saudi arabia is allowing israel to use
its airspace my guess is that if
president trump is re-elected saudi will
probably normalize relations
with israel as well we have seen that
that both serbia
and and serbia and kosovo have both cut
a deal
that involves moving embassies to
jerusalem we're going to see other
countries follow suit what we are
watching is a warming of relations
between many members of the muslim and
arab world
and the state of israel which is an
extraordinary proposition it truly is i
mean that that is something that
every president has set their eyes upon
but every president except for trump
bought into the myth that the only way
the peace was going to get done in the
middle east
was via the palestinians which was
always untrue that was never at the
heart of israeli arab relations
i mean you could tell that if you'd
studied one iota of history because the
palestinians didn't have
an independent rooting interest
effectively until 1967
since the west bank and the gaza strip
at that point were controlled by jordan
and egypt respectively
the bottom line here is that what trump
has done is he has utterly refocused the
middle east
in terms of economics in terms of
politics away from
the intransigence palestinian leadership
which is terrorist and orientation
pro-iranian and orientation
and toward a broader sort of view of the
future of the region
as a place where israel will continue to
exist and will have economic
interrelations
with other countries now to be fair
maybe obama should get half the nobel
prize if trump were to win
because it was obama's sycophancy toward
the iranian regime that allowed for that
transformation
in middle eastern politics it was
because barack obama saw fit
to try and raise the profile of the
iranian regime try to strengthen them
gave them
hundreds of billions of dollars in
access to the markets in exchange for a
promise to hold off on a nuclear weapon
for a short period of time after which
they could full-on develop a nuclear
weapon
and because of that the sunni arab world
decided hey wait a second it turns out
the jews are not the problem here
it turns out that maybe the iranians are
the problem here and the jews can
actually be helpful here
and that has radically transformed the
middle east and trump took full
advantage
of that radical realignment in the
middle east whatever the case may be
the fact is that the work that the trump
administration has done in the middle
east is far more transformative than
anything bill clinton did it is far more
than barack obama did
and it is worthwhile noting by the way
that for all the talk about trump
remember when he came into office people
on the left he's a warmonger he's gonna
come in here he's gonna start worse that
was always nonsense
if you follow trump's rhetoric one thing
he has always been is quasi isolationist
in terms of his foreign policy
and the fact is that trump is the only
president in modern american history
not to have involved himself in a war
and particularly in war without
congressional approval
in fact the only uses of force that he
has authorized are extraordinarily
targeted uses of force like the killing
of hassem solimani
in iraq the iranian terrorist leader in
iraq
or the missile firing into syria but
barack obama started a full-scale
non-congressionally authorized war in
libya that went on for months on end
and nobody said boo he had a drone war
that was spanning the globe and nobody
said boo
captain nobel prize over there so for
all of the members of the media who are
going to be
complaining about trump being nominated
for the nobel prize first of all
probably ain't going to win it but
second of all he probably deserves to
win it because honestly if i look
at the rest of the nominees who are
going to be up this year unless they are
going to give it to some sort of hong
kong activist i really don't see
who else is even nominated who has done
anything remotely as transformative
as what trump has done in the middle
east it's an actual major accomplishment
it really is
and the media have been downplaying it
because it doesn't fit with the image of
trump as a blunderer and a buffoon and a
stupid man who goes on twitter every
morning
but bottom line is if he's in charge of
his administration then he gets credit
for it
so it'll be fun to watch all of the hair
on fire this morning
in a second we're going to get to the
latest polls because the latest poll
information suggests that trump is still
a heavy underdog against joe biden has
about a
30 shot of winning re-election at this
point but the national polls are not
reflective of the state polls and the
state polls
are getting tighter in some places they
seem to be widening a little bit and
others we'll get to that
in just one moment first let us talk
about how you protect
your online safety and security there
are a lot of people who are going to
target you
for online hacking just because of of
your beliefs these days and you've seen
all of these stories
about members of left-wing online
brigades targeting people
and swamping people you've seen antifa
members who are going after people's
online
information in order to go after them i
mean all this stuff is really really
ugly and it's getting uglier out there
and this is why you really owe it to
yourself to protect
your online data your online activity
this is why i recommend using expressvpn
every time you go online big tech
companies can use your ip address to
match your internet activity to your
identity or location
which again is going to get uglier as
time goes on because a lot of these big
tech companies are censorious in the
extreme
when i use expressvpn search engines and
media sites can't see my ip address at
all my identity is masked and anonymized
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting 100 of your data to keep you
safe from people who you don't want
having it
expressvpn software takes just a minute
to set up on your computer or phone you
tap one button you're now protected so
if you're like me you believe your
internet data belongs to you and not to
giant tech companies who are not
friendly to conservatives
expressvpn is indeed the answer it's
always a good idea to protect yourself
online and expressvpn makes it happen
visit expressvpn.com
claim an exclusive offer for my fans
there's a reason i myself trust
expressvpn on all my devices
that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com for three
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn.com
ben to get started okay so looking at
the latest polls you can sense there's a
lot of unease
in the democratic circles uh first
expressed by joy behar so joy behar
yesterday on the view she obviously is
extremely worried that trump could still
win
democrats still living in the hangover
of 2016 when obviously everyone expected
that hillary clinton was going to be
president and then she emerged
to uh to be not president wandering the
woods of chappaqua lonely and alone
carrying around a replica of the oval
office desk to come for her uh here is
joy behar on
on the view trying to explain why she is
so disquieted
i'm more worried that trump could pull
this off though because
of various reasons and we all see the
polls and we see that biden is ahead
uh but uh the russian interference uh is
a alive and
kicking uh facebook is continuing to
leave all the lies on
on the pages um the postal service is
being interfered with
we've seen usps mailboxes being rounded
up and mail sorting machines deactivated
so there's a lot of cheating and on top
of that and i'll make this quick because
the five of us have to talk
the electoral college i think is an
issue and a problem okay she's a crazy
person so she just
lists off a bunch of conspiracy theories
and when you see the democrats listing
off conspiracy theories as to why
they're going to lose you can sense that
there's an awful lot of disquiet okay
the
the u.s postal service is not removing
mailboxes to prevent you from
accomplishing your mail and vote that's
idiotic the president of the united
states is not encouraging voter fraud
that's idiotic this is all very very
silly
okay and when you see it on either side
this sort of alarmism in the lead-up to
the election the process is not going to
work we're all going to die someone's
going to fraudulently steal the election
hey just stop just stop okay right now a
couple of things are happening one the
congressional ballot is tightening
okay the generic congressional ballot
which people have not really been
watching
the generic congressional ballot is
pretty much as tight as it has been
all year right now and that is kind of a
shocker considering
that trump in the national polling is
actually getting blown out right now
but if you look at the generic ballot
from usc dornsife right now
it has the republicans and the democrats
running within like four or five points
of each other and those are not the kind
of numbers that the democrats are
looking for they're looking for an eight
to ten point
congressional ballot lead they're not
seeing that what you're seeing instead
is a lot of people who
feel unease with the democratic party
overall which makes perfect sense since
the democratic party is currently
holding up relief bills
while attempting to undermine cops all
over the nation
meanwhile in the battleground states
florida looks like it is basically dead
even
and there's some polling data that is
really disquieting
for for joe biden in in florida here is
some of this data because there's a poll
yesterday that came out from nbc news
merits it shows that biden and trump are
deadlocked
which really means that trump is going
to win and the reason i say that trump's
going to win in florida
is because look at these numbers clinton
with florida latinos in 2016 for the
exit polls
clinton had 62 percent of the vote trump
had 35 percent of the vote
biden with florida latinos in 2020 is
trailing
trump 50 to 46. so
clinton beat trump by full-on 27 points
among florida latinos in 2016. trump is
now leading biden by four
that is a 31 point shift in favor of
trump among florida latinos
now among florida seniors what you're
seeing is that biden is slightly leading
trump and trump
won florida seniors in big numbers last
time but
i don't think that that is going to
outweigh that massive shift and by the
way there
are a bunch of these polls that are
showing sort of a consistent level of
increased black support for president
trump which is something you're not
seeing a lot of talk about
and the reason you're not seeing a lot
of talk about it is because people are
like is that really going to materialize
the answer is it definitely could
it definitely could and if donald trump
wins a heavier share of the hispanic and
latino vote man is that going to blow up
all
the conventional wisdom it's truly among
white college educated people the kind
of mitt romney crowd that trump has lost
a lot of votes he's lost a lot of votes
among independent women he's lost a lot
of votes among suburban
white americans but in the if he drives
heavy rural turnout and if he gets an
increased share
of black or hispanic turnout then that
could really be the death knell for the
biden campaign so when you look at the
national polling no question biden is
the favorite i mean he's up
7.3 in the real clear politics poll
average and he has trailed in
one it counts from one poll nationally
since the beginning of the year
in the battleground states however
things seem to be a lot closer again
florida
is is not the bell other state anymore i
think that trump will probably win
florida
then the question becomes can biden
replicate the supposed blue wall that
hillary was going to come up with
in michigan wisconsin pennsylvania right
now he is leading in all three
wisconsin he has the biggest lead
according to the latest polls
it seemed like it might have been
tightening up there and then there was
this fox news poll that showed that
biden
was up pretty heavy and now there are
several polls that are showing that
biden is up pretty heavily in wisconsin
even rasmussen which tends to be pretty
friendly to trump has it biden up eight
in in wisconsin cbs ugov has biden up
six
cnbc has biden up six in wisconsin so
whatever effect kenosha has had it has
not had that effect
as of yet when it comes to wisconsin
when it comes to other states like
arizona arizona looks like a state that
is moving steadily away from trump so
that's a real problem for him that means
that he has to pick up another state
right it means that it is not enough for
him to win one of michigan wisconsin
pennsylvania he needs to win two of
those
michigan seems to be relatively tight
biden has about a three-point lead in
the real club politics poll
average uh and when it looks
pennsylvania pennsylvania also seems to
be
rather tight in in fact in most of the
polling except for a new nbc news
marist poll that has biden up nine it
seems like that race is within
margin of error so the polls are a
little bit all over the place
but you have to say that the momentum
right now is still
with biden going into the election now
that could shift pretty quickly
and the reason i say that could shift
pretty quickly is because i don't think
that the trump campaign has brought out
the big gun
big guns yet the big guns for the trump
campaign
it's got to be the anti-police
campaigning by the democrats
okay and that ties into a broader
ideology that has been pushed by the
left
for generations at this point it's an
ideology called critical race theory
okay critical race theory first kind of
came to public attention back in 2012
when there was a video i remember as a
breitbart at the time and breitbart
broke a video
of derek bell who's the founder of
critical race theory from harvard law
school hugging barack obama barack obama
held a rally where he spoke
in favor of derrick bell being granted
tenure at harvard law school even though
he hadn't done a lot of real academic
work
and the reason that derek bell became
the celebrated figure is because he was
the father of so-called critical race
theory i'm going to explain what
critical race theory is in a second
because all of the intersectionality and
wokism that you are seeing dominating
american politics today
springs from critical race theory it was
being taught until the last five seconds
in the federal government itself until
the trump administration stepped in
and stopped it and that critical race
theory ideology has driven
a lot of the democrats thinking now
they're not going to call it critical
race theory because they don't actually
know the origins of their own philosophy
this happens a lot in politics where
there's a lot of highfalutin talk on
college campuses
about the foundations of a particular
philosophy
over time it filters down in sort of
bumper sticker slogans and the no
silence no peace kind of stuff
starts off as a higher philosophy he
silences violence microaggression
all of american politics is systems of
power that starts off
at a higher level of discussion that is
much more abstracted eventually it is
funneled down to
common policymakers and to broad groups
of people who then rally and riot in the
streets
but the origins of that philosophy are
really really ugly critical race theory
is an ugly philosophy is a racist
philosophy it essentially substitutes
substitutes race for class in marx's
theory we'll get to that in a second and
it does matter
because you have to understand exactly
what people are thinking in order to
understand
why they are doing what they are doing
with regard to for example law
enforcement
and criminality we'll get to that in
just one moment first
you might be feeling a little bit less
safe these days as you watch rising
crime in america's major cities all over
the united states and you know there are
situations happening all over the united
states on a regular basis
where people are victimized by violent
crime there's a reason why gun sales are
going up
and up and up and there's a reason why
you need to know how to use a gun we've
seen too many cases recently where
somebody uses a gun to protect
themselves
and then they end up being dragged in
front of a court on charges
now you need to know what to do and
nightmares do come true sometimes but
you have to know what to do you have to
know what your rights are
in this day and age you need a gun to
protect your family and yourself but you
need more than that you need 100
free copy of the complete concealed
carry and family defense guide from the
united states concealed carry
association it's 164 pages it comes the
bonus audio version so you can listen
whenever you want just take shapiro to
87.222 you'll get instant access and a
chance to win a thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family text shapiro to 87 222 right now
seriously you owe it to yourself
to if you're a law abiding citizen on a
gun but also know exactly how to use it
what your rights are and have a group
that will come to your defense legally
speaking if god forbid you have to use a
weapon in self-defense get your 100 free
copy
of the complete concealed carry and
family defense guide from the us cca
they are excellent people and
you get a chance to win a thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family text shapiro to eighty seven two
two two
again text shapiro to eighty seven two
two two right now
shapiro to eighty seven two two two okay
so
critical race theory has become a hot
issue again the reason it's become a hot
issue is because the trump
administration
put forward through the office of
management and budget as we discussed
yesterday
a letter saying that they're not going
to allow the teaching of critical race
theory
on government campuses anymore there
shall be no more dissemination of this
nonsense
in government offices and it was being
used for diversity training okay it's
just a propagandistic effort to declare
the united states and its institutions
systemically racist
to suggest that all white people are
complicit in that racism are part of a
racist system
and that in fact all white people are
inherently racist because they work
within systems
that generate unequal outcomes as i've
discussed before the perspective here
is that any system that generates an
unequal outcome between groups of people
which is every system on the planet but
if you have a system that generates
unequal outcomes between racial groups
then the system itself is racist
and if you are quote-unquote complicit
in the system then this means that you
yourself are racist even if you've never
done a racist thing
and even if you have no racist intent
okay so the federal government was was
teaching this
literally teaching this in government
offices they were they were distributing
power points talking about how all white
americans
are racist by the new definition of
racism and the trump administration
stepped in said we're not doing this
anymore and now
you've got democratic congress people
and members of the media who are
either pretending that this is a
terrible thing or saying
that it doesn't matter at all so al
green the democratic representative
from new york he says that it is
anti-american to end the sort of
critical
racial theory training that was
happening in the federal government
sorry from texas
in the president's america it is
anti-american to have diversity and
inclusion
as an agenda item
unfortunately he has an america
that um is shrinking it is anti-american
to do what the president is doing and
that is to ban diversity training
and call it anti-america the president
is doing the country of disservice with
this kind of behavior
so the way the critical race theory
hides its
sort of ugly philosophy is by hiding
behind this diversity training nonsense
they say we're training you for
diversity you're not they're not
training you for diversity
they're training you in an actual theory
don lemon over at cnn denies that
critical race theory is even an
even a thing he says that it's just
another bogey man but that is because
he wishes to he he wishes you not to
know the truth which is the critical
race theory
is in fact an animating philosophy that
is filtered down through a variety of of
of channels and streams via things
like intersectionality
via things like identity politics here's
don lemon dismissing it and then we'll
discuss exactly what it is
this whole idea i don't understand well
i do understand what's going on
of critical race theory are we going
back to the 80s because this
all played out in the 1980s this whole
thing about critical race theory in
politics
it is another boogeyman yeah we're going
right try to scare people we're going
back to the 80s there's no
new nothing new about critical races
that's scary just go back and do
do a google search theory and politics
i'll tell you
look at these geniuses okay so so an
idea that was ugly in the 1980s
and has now reached full animated form
in today's american politics is not
relevant because it happened in the
1980s
it's weird how everything that leftists
don't want to talk about is relegated to
the past
but everything that they want to talk
about that is from like the 1840s
is happening right now you see this all
the time in left-wing writing you'll see
a tanahasi coates piece where he'll cite
some evil instance of the of the brutal
treatment of a slave in 1810
fast forward 200 years and then he'll
just say well it's exactly the same
today but if you're talking about
an actual active ideology in the united
states like critical race theory then
you see folks like don lemon and chris
cuomo pretending that it has no impact
on modern american thought so what
exactly is critical race theory and why
does it matter
so back in 2012 i reported extensively
on this uh i remember that some of the
professors in harvard law school
were big fans of critical race theory
critical race theory springs from a
generalized
study of of the law called critical
legal studies critical legal studies is
the idea that there is no such thing as
a neutral principle
in law in fact there is no such thing as
objectivity in law
judges cannot determine via neutral
principles the outcome of a case
instead the way that judges actually
determine what it is they want to rule
is they look to their own politics and
then they just figure out a way to
finagle those politics into a ruling
so in other words there's no such thing
as true philosophy there's no such thing
as truth there's no such thing as
objectivity
all there is are subjective points of
view and people who wish to cram down
their power on you
so all human dynamics all human
interrelationships are about power
right none of them are about higher
ideals none of them are about
big ideas all that human relationships
are about is one group of people
attempting
to use its power against another group
of people okay that is the critical
legal studies movement a branch of the
critical legal studies movement was
started by derek bell it's called
critical race theory
critical race theory is the idea that
all human relationships
are not just driven by power but driven
by racial power so racial power
undergirds every system
all systems are driven by racial power
in fact there are some core assumptions
made by critical
race theory so as i say this really
began in the late 70s and early
1980s this is me writing for breitbart
back in 2012
in which some scholars perturbed by what
they perceived as a loss of momentum
in the movement for racial equality
began to doubt that the constitutional
and legal system itself
had the capacity for change this
criticism mirrored a marxist attack
long voiced in academia that the
constitution was a capitalist document
incapable of allowing for the
redistributionist change
necessary to create a more equal world
so in other words the the outcome of the
civil rights movement which was
okay now all the rules are equal for
everybody go out and play the game
that wasn't enough because this still
left in place these capitalist
structures and these capitalist
structures were bad
and they were bad because they were
unfair and therefore the way to tear
down those structures was to castigate
all of those structures and as
inherently
racist the marxist criticism of the
system was called critical theory the
racial criticism of the system was
called critical race theory it was a
direct offshoot
of critical theory so in a second i'm
gonna get to what are the core beliefs
of critical race theory and how we how
are we seeing those play out in every
area of american life because we are
watching this play out in literally
every area of american life
right now despite the best protestations
of idiots like don lemon and chris cuomo
combined
iq slightly above that of an inanimate
object we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you need
a great couch you need a great couch
okay right now you're spending an awful
lot of time at home
and you got this whole beat up sofa
looks like garbage don't you need a
couch that is personalized for you
you've been hearing me talk for a long
time about my helix mattress it's
fantastic right i sleep better because
i'm on my helix mattress but i've got
even more exciting news helix has gone
beyond the boudoir they started making
sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
directly to your door so what makes an
all form sofa really cool well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize a sofa using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores
you can pick your fabric it is spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs sofa size shape to
make sure it's perfect for you and your
home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on
if you want your all-form sofa to grow
and change with you when you move
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa it could take weeks or even months
to arrive and you would need someone to
come and assemble it in your home
all form takes just three to seven days
to arrive in mail and you can put it
together yourself in just a few minutes
we did it ourselves
i have a fantastic all form sofa my kids
try to beat the hell out of it but
this thing is durable and it is
comfortable it is awesome i picked out
the three
seat sofa with chase in the sand color
with espresso legs it is fabulous
if getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky don't worry you get
100 days to decide if you want to keep
it
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free give you
a full refund and they've got a forever
warranty literally forever so
find your perfect sofa today check out
allform.com ben
and again when you use that slash man
you get 20 off all orders all form.com
ben go check them out right now
allform.com for 20
off okay so back to critical race theory
so what exactly are the key tenets of
critical race theory
well there's a primer called critical
race theory by richard delgado who is
one of the founders of the movement's
founders and
john stefancek and they set out some
basic principles one
racism is ordinary not aberrational so
in other words
we used to believe that the normal
course of human events is that you were
nice to people and treated them as
individuals
critical race theory believes that
everyone is racist only some racism
matters because if you're in a position
of power then your racism matters but if
you're not then you can't be racist
against anybody else
racism is ordinary not aberrational
right you are just by dint of being a
racist particularly if you're white
two our system of white over color
ascendancy serves important purposes
both psychic
and material right what that means is
that every system in the united states
is rife with racism
all of our institutions are shot through
with racism if this sounds familiar it's
because this is all the same stuff you
are seeing the leaders of the black
lives matter movement proclaim
you're seeing politicians proclaim this
joe biden proclaims this
he would have rejected critical race
theory in the 1980s but now joe biden
mouths platitudes about systemic
police racism right that is swallowing
hook line and sinker the critical race
theory thought
that all systems are shot through with
racism and that all systems that exist
are about white over other colors
ascendancy
which again is weird because the highest
earning subgroups in the united states
are
indian americans and asian americans as
i wrote back in 2012 when taken together
these principles have serious
ramifications first they suggest that
legal rules that stand for equal
treatment under law like the 14th
amendment
can remedy quote only the most blatant
forms of discrimination in other words
the equal protection clause that says
you have to have equal protection under
the laws that only remedies laws that
overtly discriminate but what about all
of these subtle forms
of discrimination in american society
well crt critical race theory argues the
system is too corrupted
too bad on the notion of white supremacy
for equal protection of the laws to ever
be a reality
the system has to be made unequal in
order to compensate for the innate
racial superiority of the white majority
innate racial power of the white
majority
second the principles suggest that even
measures taken to alleviate unequal
protection under the law for example
brown versus the board of education
desegregation were actually taken
to serve white interests derek bell
actually believed this right derek bell
actually said that brown versus board
had only been decided in order to
prevent the soviet union
from using american racial prejudice as
a public relations baton
to wield against white majority united
states
now there are some internal
contradictions in critical racial theory
that come up
pretty regularly right some of the crt
writers
believe like martin luther king believed
that racial lines are basically
arbitrary that race is a social
construct
some believe that race is inherently and
inextricably tied to identity
delgado and stefan check some of the
founders of critical racial theory they
say minority status in other words
brings brings with it it presumes
competence to speak about race
and racism so racism so so race itself
is a social construct but you only get
to speak if you're a member of a
particular race which means that your
racial identity
has to lie in victimhood and this is
what we've seen
right that independent racial identity
is apparently
not really a thing and shouldn't be a
thing according to members of the
critical race theory
brigade but they also believe that race
is the most important thing about you
even though race is a social construct
so how can both of those two things be
true well you can do that if you turn
race
into a statement not about biology but
if race is a statement about victimhood
at the hands of the system and that's
what crt does so this is how they can
say
that black americans who don't agree
with the left people like candace owens
or thomas sowell
or clarence thomas are not truly black
because racial identity
is about victimology in its essence and
the only way it can be truly black is to
fight against those systems
and this is a very disturbing theory
obviously
what this does it sets up a an
extraordinary hierarchy where
you have to be a member of a minority
who opposes the system in order to be
heard
about the system itself jeffrey pyle
summed this up at the boston college law
review say critical race theorists
attacked the very foundations of the
classical liberal legal order
including equality theory legal
reasoning enlightenment rationalism
and neutral principles of constitutional
law these liberal values they allege
have no enduring basis and principles
but are mere social constructs
calculated to legitimate white supremacy
the rule of law according to critical
race theorists is a false promise of
principled government and they have lost
patience with false promises you see
exactly this in the streets today you
see exactly this this is what people are
shouting about
it's what people are yelling about and
it's why people who
should not for any reason be elevated in
american public discourse have been
elevated
in american public discourse it's why
the 1619 project exists
to carry forth the notion that all of
america is based on power dynamics
between races it is not based on
fundamental principles that bring us
together as a creedal nation
and you're seeing it play out in the way
that the left reacts to current events
it's pretty amazing there was this story
that came out and
not all that long ago a couple of maybe
three three four days ago in which a
professor
outed herself professor from a major
college she outed herself
as actually a a white person so she is a
black person
but she outed herself as a white person
she was a jewish lady from kansas city
who'd been masquerading
as black for years and years and years
and years and she'd actually been
nominated for like frederick douglass
prizes and for harriet tubman prizes and
all this kind of stuff
okay she was a teacher at george
washington university and a quote
unquote expert
in african history her name is jessica
krug okay the fact is that she was
well respected until the moment when she
outed herself she was
well respected despite the fact that she
was insane
hey this is a clip of jessica krug
defending a black gang's
machete murder of a 15 year old this did
not end her academic career it ended her
academic career when she said
oh by the way i'm not a member of the
race i purport to be a member of here's
jessica krug not all that long ago we
have to consider a radical moment
in 2018 in which people are using
machetes to hack apart a 15 year old boy
who's working with the police the way
the story about his innocence
and the inherent violence of the people
who hacked him apart become the
narrative we tell
about about how the loss of innocence is
the story we mourn
and it's so much more difficult to
understand what kind of freedom
could we achieve by being willing to
confront those within the community who
are working
against the interests of the community
as a whole at the end of a machete
okay so this is her basically suggesting
that we have to consider the broader
concerns of people who machete hacked a
15 year old's death
okay this sort of stuff is considered
deregular at america's major
universities
seriously i mean this sort of stuff is
super common at america's universities
and it ties into this broader theory
which is that all of america's about
power politics so if somebody who is of
color does something really really bad
even to another person
who is of color that criminality is of
no consequence and the reason the
criminality is of no consequence
is because these are quote-unquote
powerless people fighting within the
system
and so anything bad they do is
attributable to the system that has put
them in a position of subjugation
this is the only way to explain honestly
it's the only way to explain why a
democratic party that used to believe in
law and order yes
joe biden used to be a law and order guy
joe biden in 1994 was the sponsor
of a criminal bill that was designed to
put bad people in jail and it succeeded
in doing so the fact that he is running
ahead long away from the 1994 criminal
bill says so much about the democratic
party right now
because here is what the chart of
american crime looked like
up to the 1990s okay it looked like this
it was straight up
it was straight up from 1960 to 1994 the
violent crime rates in the united states
rose
year on year extraordinarily radically
and then after 1994
and things like that crime bill and
additional policing across the nation
the crime rate begins to decline and it
begins to decline it declines
extraordinarily i mean it's an
incredible story
there's a great book by barry lasser
called the rise and fall of violent
crime in america and it's all about the
the rise of crime and the decline in
crime and it is directly connected to
broken windows policing
is directly connected to sentencing
criminals to periods of time in prison
and keeping them in prison
right is directly connected to taking
crime seriously but in order to take
crime seriously you have to believe that
the criminals are the bad guys
right now the democratic party has
decided the criminals are not in fact
the bad guys the criminals are just
symptoms of deeper underlying ills with
the racist
systemic american system and the
predictable result of this is that
they've taken sides with the criminals
against the cops
there's no other way to read what kamala
harris and joe biden have been doing
with the jacob lake family in kenosha or
what they've been doing by flirting with
the black lives matter movement and
antifa
other than they've made the decision
that critical race theory
is in fact correct 1619 project is
correct all of america is power politics
and power politics is all this is about
and the only way to rectify the system
is to tear it down from the inside and
joe biden will be a trojan horse for
that
he'll say that he's going to he'll make
white people feel comfortable with the
idea he's only going to tinker with the
system
but in essence he's winking and nodding
at people who want to tear down the
entire system by the way they're not
going to be satisfied with joe biden
even if joe biden wanted to be an
obstacle to them they ain't going to be
satisfied with him
they weren't satisfied with barack obama
the radical the radical left
the ilhan omars of the system who
continue to claim that america is a
systemically racist unjust oppressive
place
those people are going to have control
of the of the levers of the democratic
party for the foreseeable future
can we get to the predictable results of
this because you can see what is
happening
all over the united states as police
chiefs are forced to resign we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let us talk about the fact that right
now it can be tough to find great
employees and it can be tough to find a
great employer this is why
you need a zip recruiter in fact if
you're looking for a job and not taking
advantage of technology like zip
recruiter you are losing
the edge monica starks could relate she
needed to hire for a pivotal role
at her construction company gs group but
was having a tough time finding the
right person
especially with so many candidates out
there so she switched to zip recruiter
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you
it finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience for your job
and then actively invites them to apply
which is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire which is
how monica found lamont jenkins
she said zip recruiter sent lemon's
profile to her around five minutes after
she posted her job
because he was a great match for the
role through zip recruiter monica's
company has hired everyone from
accountants to project managers to field
scientists
monica's not the only employer who loves
zipper crew we love zip recruiter here
at daily wire we use zip recruiter every
time we look for somebody to fill a job
opening let's say that you had an
employee unless he had a producer who
just
every one morning he was charged into
the makeup room and said
do you have my money and let's say you
want to replace that employee because
what the hell is that employee talking
about
well producer nick you'd find yourself
on the breadlines thanks to zip
recruiter and we'd find someone
who doesn't spend his time a whitland
and sitting on his porch picking at the
banjo
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
see for yourself how zip recruiter makes
hiring faster and easier try it right
now for free that is correct free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter dot com daily wire go
check them out
right now okay we're gonna get to the
predictable results
the field results of crt in action but
first as part of our daily wire audience
there are a lot of ways you can take in
the podcast you can listen on apple
podcast spotify another podcast app
you can also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook over at dailywire.com
bottom line
we are making our content available to
you anywhere you want to watch or listen
and now we're introducing a new upgraded
experience daily wire is now on apple tv
and roku so members can enjoy all of the
visual elements
on this podcast on your big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wear on apple
tv or roku and download it today you
have to be an insider member to watch
live so head on over to dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15 off your membership purchase
this deal won't last long so act fast if
you want a lot if you want live shows on
your big screen
plus this the one of a kind highly
coveted often imitated never duplicated
makes julian fry's leftist years tumblr
again that is dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with codewatch and
download
the daily weather on your apple tv and
roku today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so if you're asking yourself why is the
mainline democrats mainstream democrats
are out there in kenosha praising
praising
an alleged rapist and ripping on the
police
this is the bleed down effect of
critical race theory now you don't have
to know where it came from i don't think
kamala harris is an expert on critical
race studies i don't think that
joe biden even knows where he is right
now let alone knows what critical race
theory is
it doesn't matter ideologies have
consequences and as they bleed through
the body politic and as they are
imbibed broadly speaking it's like a
toxic poison
in the water you don't have to get that
much of it in order for it to affect
your thinking and you can sense that the
democratic party
has gotten some of this which is why
they are backing away from the
law and order sister soldier moments of
the clinton days and
and towards something new and more
radical and really old and more radical
right all the stuff that was considered
radical in 1983 is now considered
somewhat mainstream
in the democratic party well the
predictable result of this when you rip
on the cops and when you treat
every isolated incident of police
brutality as indicative
of broader systemic oppression and when
you take bad examples
right when you just look up the jacob
blake case which is a justified police
shooting by all available evidence
or when you look at the case of for
example daniel pruitt in rochester where
it looks as though the police officers
in that case did not in fact kill daniel
prude by the available evidence it looks
like he died of excited delirium
right which which happens when you are
high on pcp and smashing windows and
walking naked
down the street and then you die of a
heart attack excited to learn is an
actual medical condition
very often the cops are blamed for
asphyxia in these conditions there is
not a lot of evidence that suggests
asphyxia has to do with excited delirium
by the way this was also implicated
in the george floyd case well it turns
out that when you target the cops
as the root of all evil the predictable
happens and cops leave and this is
what's happening in rochester
according to abc news after days of
protests against the rochester police
department in light of the death of
daniel prude its top officer and his
deputy announced tuesday they are
retiring from the force
along with the police chief six other
department leaders announced they will
vacate their roles
rochester police chief laurent
singletary who is in fact black said in
a statement he was honored to serve the
city in upstate new york for 20 years
and commended his staff
however he said the protests and
criticism of his handling of the
investigation into the march 23rd
incident are quote an attempt to destroy
my character and integrity
he said as a man of integrity i will not
sit idly by while outside entities
attempt to destroy my character
the members of the rochester police
department and the greater rochester
community
know my reputation and know what i stand
for
so he quit kind of on the spur of the
moment and he quit because he was tired
of being labeled part of a racist system
again he is a black man
who's been serving in rochester for 20
years mayor lovely warren
informed the rochester city council that
in addition to singletary the entire
command staff announced it would be
vacating
their roles today she said none of the
police leaders were asked to resign
but basically the police union laid the
blame at the foot of the mayor's office
the rochester police locust club said
quote
the events that the events that have
unfolded today have taken us completely
by surprise as they have everyone else
what is clear is that the problems of
leadership go directly to the mayor's
office
our priority now is on dedicated men and
women who despite unprecedented
challenges continue to do
a very difficult job okay well this is
what happens when you rip the cops and
suggest that the cops themselves
are the problem when they are the ones
policing crime by the way it is not just
a black police chief in rochester
stepping down it is also the dallas
black female police chief you renee hall
she has resigned she abruptly announced
her resignation on tuesday amid eroding
support on the city council
stemming from her department's handling
of protests over the policing of african
americans
she's the first woman to lead the dallas
department she's held the position since
2017.
in her resignation letter she expressed
gratitude for serving in the post but
acknowledged she'd faced
challenges in recent months
she said it has not been easy she said
much has been accomplished by standing
together in support of community
policing
and changes in the way our officers
performed their duties in 2020.
what apparently was the big problem well
when she reported on the protest
she reported that protesters were
targeting in the police but apparently
did not discuss some of the harsh
measures employed by officers
against demonstrators so
mayor eric johnson said that he had not
spoken to the chief but was not terribly
surprised
he said that um he had been openly
frustrated by the chief's unsuccessful
efforts to reverse
violent crime several police chiefs
around the country have resigned or been
fired in recent months
over all of this police chiefs in
seattle atlanta louisville and tucson
arizona
have left the police chief in rochester
new york left
hall came from came from detroit she was
deputy police chief in detroit
to dallas and she left as well so we are
seeing
police chiefs all over the united states
leave their jobs because they're not
willing to be subjected to the rigors of
critical race theory in which the police
are systemically racist even if they are
being led by people
who are minorities in fact right carmen
best in seattle another case in point
was a woman of color who was forced to
step down as police chief when they cut
her salary
for the great crime of not being allowed
to police crime
what's incredible how far left has has
the left move here how far left is the
democratic party moving
al sharpton has now become the voice of
reason right al sharpton
yesterday he chided people in the media
for trying to defund the police
he said only latte liberals in the
hamptons support this here's al sharpton
morphing magically into sean hannity
we need to reimagining how we do
policing
but when you are talking about the fact
that a
we are in the areas where that is
inundated with guns
that has this uh serious problems of our
people being given guns that can't even
get a summer program
to take all policing off is something
that i think uh
a latte liberal may go for as they sit
around the hamptons discussing this as
some academic problem
but people living on the ground need
proper policing
okay when when you have left al sharpton
behind
you guys may have moved too far this is
captain i'm going to completely fake a
crime with tuan braley and blame a local
d.a
and the cops for it and al sharpton's
like you guys were going too far for me
okay so how far has critical race theory
gone it's infected every
every element of american culture okay
today's example of american culture
being infected with this nonsense is the
new oscars
standard so people are always saying
like why do you care about the oscars
you know you say you don't care about
first of all i've never said i don't
care about culture i wrote an entire
book on television called primetime
propaganda
culture matters a lot because as my
mentor andrew breitbart said
culture is upstream of politics more
people are affected by culture than are
affected by politics
by the way this is the reason why people
on left get super pissed
whenever i mention culture if i make fun
of cardi b and suggest
that a song in which a woman proclaims
that being a is empowering
is actually not good for women and when
i mock the lyrics
for being trite ridiculous and
physically repulsive
which which they are okay that when that
in no ways that song sexy when you
mention the fact that that
idiotic song has five different people
writing it and that they have come up
with the least i'd say the least
inspiring vision of femininity maybe
ever created in pop culture when you say
that
then people i'm left get mad why are you
so mad about culture bro why are you so
mad
okay culture matters because people
imbibe it by literally the hundreds of
millions
so why do the oscars matter because
people invite movies by the hundreds
of millions so now the oscars has
finally decided to make formal what was
always informal so every year
before the oscars i would do the woke
oscars i've been doing this for for
several years where i would try and
predict the outcome of particular oscar
races simply by looking at the number of
woke check boxes
the movies checked and so moonlight
obviously was gonna check a lot of woke
boxes
it was both gay and black the shape of
water checked a bunch of woke boxes it
had a gay character it had a black
character
it had a woman having sex with a fish so
obviously all of the woke boxes
were checked and and you can you we've
been able to do this for for quite a
long time at the oscars well now the
oscars is making it formal and this is
incredible
okay so the oscars has now decided that
they are going to have formal standards
for eligibility for best picture
according to the la times developed over
the past few months by a special task
force
as part of the organization's academy
aperture 2025 initiative
the standards encompass both
representation on screen into
in the types of stories being told and
the actors involved as well as behind
the scenes in the makeup of the crew
and and in the inclusivity of the
companies involved so in other words
you can either be eligible for best
picture oscar by mimicking exactly the
narratives that the hollywood
woke critical race theory left wants you
to tell or by having an internship
program with a few black kids
that's that's i love the the get out of
jail free clause
is this an internship program that you
can just kind of bolt on to your company
to be eligible for best picture a film
must meet at least two standards across
four categories
on-screen representation themes and
narratives creative leadership and
project team
industry access and opportunities and
audience development
within each category are a variety of
criteria involving the inclusion of
people
in underrepresented groups including
women people of color lgbtq people and
those with cognitive or physical
disabilities
so first of all if you add together all
those groups of people that is not a
minority in the united states first of
all women are a sheer majority
in the united states but in any case the
only standards to qualify
for best picture before involves the
running time over 40 minutes which uh is
makes sense since it's just what's the
best picture or not what's the best woke
picture but now
they have decided to actually mandate
what kind of content
is eligible so this means that a bunch
of recent nominees would not be eligible
like 1917 a world war one film which
featured a bunch of white people because
guess what world war one
featured a lot of white people as it
turns out the gangster epic the irishman
which is in fact about the italian and
irish
mafia like that that like
okay apparently all of this is no no
longer any good
in fact a lot of great movies are no
okay so here are the standards on-screen
representation themes and narratives
to achieve standard a the film must meet
one of the following criteria first
lead or significant supporting actors at
least one of the lead actors or
significant supporting actors is from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
asian hispanic black indigenous middle
eastern native hawaiian
or other underrepresented race or
ethnicity
two general ensemble cast at least 30
percent of all at 30
of all actors in secondary and more
minor roles are from at least two of the
following underrepresented groups
women racial or ethnic group lgbtq plus
or people with cognitive or physical
disabilities
who are deaf or hard of hearing so i
guess that if the irishman just has a
bunch of extras in the background where
black they're good
and then finally main storyline subject
matter the main storyline theme or
narrative of the film
is centered on an underrepresented group
women racial or ethnic group lgbtq plus
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities or who are deaf or hard of
hearing
so very exciting stuff they're actually
going to mandate what the story lines
are for you to be eligible for best
picture
so that rules out probably two-thirds of
the former
academy award nominees okay other ways
that you can achieve eligibility
you can have a bunch of um women racial
or ethnic minorities lgbtq plus people
with cognitive or physical disabilities
in creative or leadership positions
or you can have people in other key
roles who are of this or
30 of the film crew should be from
underrepresented groups
also you could have paid apprenticeship
paid apprenticeship
and internship opportunities and
training opportunities and skills
developments ah there's the internship
program that allows you to get out of
jail free you can still make the
irishman
so long as you have an internship
program that features underrepresented
groups
and finally you have to have
representation in marketing publicity
and distribution okay so we're now just
doing socialist propaganda is what we're
doing here we're now just doing sjw
propaganda why
because again hollywood is about
relationships of power it's about power
dynamics
it's all critical race theory and the
only way to overthrow that is by
mandating from the top down
exactly what kind of stories can be told
and how people are represented
in those stories every area of culture
will be overtaken
by the sjw woke culture video games too
will be overtaken by the sjw woke
culture
so ea madden which has really crappy
ratings
user ratings like 0.2 rating for ea
madden madden nfl 21
is welcoming back colin kaepernick now
you may be saying to yourself
wait a second wednesday did colin
kaepernick leave the nfl i mean isn't
that a human being
was not actually played in the nfl like
four years
as in like the last year that he played
in the nfl was 2016 and
currently i'm looking at the calendar it
is in fact 2020
and isn't it also true that uh his qb
rating in his last year was
absolutely awful and his completion
rating was not very good
and that he in fact is not a very good
quarterback and was benched for the
immortal blaine gabbard well according
to ea sports he actually is good again
he's good he's really good so ea madden
has decided again
critical race theory stuff we have to
insert colin kaepernick back into the
sport
and pretend he is a good quarterback so
here is ea madden quote
colin kaepernick is one of the top free
agents in football and a starting
caliber quarterback
oh thanks ea madden thanks for the info
i didn't know that because it's not true
the team at ea sports along with
millions of madden nfl fans
want to see him back in our game we've
had a long relationship with colin
through madden nfl
and worked through our past soundtrack
mistakes knowing that our ea sports
experiences are platforms for players to
create we want to make madden nfl a
place that reflects colin's position
and talent and rates him as a starting
qb and empowers our fans to express
their hopes for the future of football
we've worked with collins to make this
possible we're excited to bring it to
you all today
starting today in madden nfl 21 fans can
put colin kaepernick at the helm of any
nfl team in franchise mode
as well as play with him and play now we
look forward to seeing colin on madden
nfl teams everywhere
so uh that is hi hilarious that is hi
hilarious so first of all i'm just going
to point out that this rates him higher
than like
cam newton and a bunch of other starting
quarterbacks in the nfl
all he had to do is uh is be
unbelievably crappy
his lifetime record he has uh 28 wins
and 30 losses he had one good year
followed by
three not very good ones and lost his
starting job to blame gabbard
so really really solid stuff really
really good
he is rated above a bunch of actual
starting quarterbacks in the nfl
and the way you win the super bowl
apparently in madden ea is by kneeling
you just hit that x button at the bottom
of your controller and you kneel and you
you automatically win now if you sense
that there is some cultural hypocrisy to
all of this
that basically you know people are
pretending to imbibe from the crt
handbook but really they're just doing
performative wokeness in order to
buy off people who are more radical
you'd be exactly right
because when the real money is at the
table when the real money is at stake
they're not doing any of this stuff
perfect case in point is china okay so
disney
is it's not just the nba right so the
nba does the performance of woke stuff
the nba does the performance will stuff
all the time right the nba has black
lives matter painted on the court and
you can put education reform
it's like education reform tatum going
up for a dunk because on the back of his
jersey and all this nonsense but then
when it comes to can you condemn china
nope
can you condemn them for taking over
hong kong nope can you condemn them for
you know helping you set up like a slave
factory for
little kids playing basketball nope so
the nba knows where it's bread is butter
disney
also knows where it's bread is buttered
this is the greatest contrast right
america sucks
but every other dictatorship is good
this
bespeaks the the lack of sincerity of
the
corporate willingness to kowtow to the
sjw crowd
so last year last year disney's ceo
went after the state of georgia remember
the state of georgia passed a law that
restricted abortion
and bob iger of disney said they will
not film in georgia until this stops
remember all of hollywood did this
all of hollywood was like we're not
filming in georgia until all of this
stops
however they are perfectly happy to film
in zhang province
and thank the chinese government in the
process chandrang
province is the home of concentration
camps holding 1.5
million muslim uyghurs so they're
perfectly okay with
complete tyranny in china they're just
not okay with people being pro-life in
georgia
this is the hypocrisy right the american
system is bad all other systems
are not worthy of criticism it's just
america that is particularly bad
and the corporate system is willing to
reward this because they know they're
not going to lose bucks in the united
states but they will lose bucks in china
real really high level stuff here and
it's funny the critical race theory
progenitors will suggest that neutral
principles like the declaration of
independence and the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment that these
are lies that really all of human
relations are power dynamics
okay and now you have the corporations
basically proving that all of their
highfalutin words about racial justice
are merely power dynamics that they get
to spout when there are no consequences
but as soon as there are consequences
they back off of those
full scale okay well we've reached the
end
of today's program but we'll be back
here a little bit later today with much
much more including
all of the latest on covid and coveted
controversy
and the stopping of of vaccine
development we'll get to why all of that
happened in the meantime
try to keep calm out there stay calm oh
we'll be well and we'll see you here a
little bit later on ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stephens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
you